i think we know quite a good bit about
pharmaceuticals in european rivers in uk
rivers so we came into this with a
decent understanding of what we would
expect to see um so glasgow came as the
as the most contaminated river in the uk
and we were slightly surprised by the
levels that we saw in in glasgow i think
there were some indications that
potentially uh
something like a combined sewage
overflow could have contributed to to
those concentrations but on the large we
we sort of found what we expected in the
uk
um however of course many places of the
world we we found surprising results of
course
yeah absolutely well let's let's come on
uh to that but before i think it was the
river clyde wasn't it that you were
talking about when you when you were
talking about the glasgow river um i
wonder whether uh we can just go into a
bit more detail for people to understand
how worried they should be what can
these sorts of chemicals that you found
actually do first of all to the marine
life or not marine life the river life
that's in that's in there but then also
to us as humans can they get into our
drinking water and what can they do to
us there
i think it's very unlikely that um
pharmaceuticals would be of a harm to
humans directly in terms of drinking
water or even bathing in the rivers or
swimming
what you find is that you would have to
consume a vast amount of water
in order to come even close to a
therapeutic dose of some of the most
highly concentrated uh chemicals we find
in the river water where i think this
could potentially affect humans in the
long run particularly with the effects
of climate change um beginning to to
show themselves are are endpoints such
as antimicrobial resistance so this is
the concept that bacteria become
resistant to the effects of the
medicines that we use to treat their
infections um the likes of the world
health organization and the united
nations have placed this among the top
global health threats to humans at the
moment and the environmental component
of this
we're beginning to learn quite a bit
more about and and to realize that there
is a significant aspect of the
environment involved in problems like
this
certainly and we know that there is this
sense that the water that we drinking is
the same water that's been recycled many
times over
what
should people be doing to try and avoid
this is it is this about people flushing
uh drugs or unused pills or whatever
down down the toilet or what what's
happening that's allowing these drugs to
get into the river
yeah and i'll just touch on what you've
just said is it's actually very
interesting points i mean you're right
the water that's that's on this planet
right now that we're drinking in our our
tea and our coffee right now has been
here for as long as the planet has
and what we're doing to it kind of have
effects on the aquatic organisms and
indeed us into the future in terms of
what people can do
i think
of course not not flushing drugs down
the toilet
you can bring your pharmaceuticals back
to pharmacies who can properly dispose
of them and avoid them getting into the
aquatic environments
in the first place and there are many
issues around the proper use of
medicines for example i mean in many
parts of the world where we've conducted
these studies
you can buy antibiotics over-the-counter
with very little or no questions asked
and and they can be used to treat
ailments that have nothing to do with
the effective use of an antibiotic a
viral affection will not be will not be
fought at all by an antibiotic and yet
you can buy them in many parts of the
world for such causes and that that's
done quite frequently so the proper use
of medicine and being cognizant about
what your health care providers tell you
about the proper use of medicine is a
very important aspect to consider for
every one of us
certainly and i'm really interested
actually what you're saying there the
public health
uh differences between different
countries did was that reflected in the
water so for example countries where
modern medicines are not used did they
have fewer of these chemicals or were
there other things getting into their
water supplies
yeah we did see we did examine some
places where there is very little
anthropogenic impact in terms of modern
medicine so for example there was a
remote village in
the the tropical rainforest of venezuela
that we didn't find these
pharmaceuticals largely because they
they aren't used there
so these these places are of course
becoming more and more rare
as time goes on but there are still
untouched places in terms of these types
of contaminants in the environment
okay really good to know thank you so
much dr john wilkinson there who led the
study and the takeaway point from there
is do not flush your drugs down the
toilet give them back to the pharmacy